when you have a player of uh of Russ's
caliber uh being asked to come off the
bench and provide that kind of bench
spark um what do you lose from that and
I guess what does that kind of say about
the sacrifice that everyone on this team
will have to kind of um yeah I mean uh
that's what it takes um you know if you
whatever coach needs um you know you got
to you know kind of suck it up and
um just you know go go with it you know
what I mean just see what uh see what
the opportunity presents uh for the team
and uh yeah I mean know I've been there
before uh starting my career and you
know just um just every year just uh
trying to you know see different ways
you can win a basketball game and uh I
think he's he's going to be good um you
know it's going to take time uh for us
all to figure it out but um I think he
did well came in in the game and hit a
hit a big three for us and uh got some
stops great defense so um yeah hey Kawai
um with Russ volunteering to come off
the bench I'm just curious if that's
something he discussed with you guys um
before he text the
coach um I mean he just uh we all trying
to figure out ways to win and um like I
said before uh you know it's it's a not
notice very noticeable sacrifice that
he's making just because he's not
starting uh but um you know if he makes
that uh leap like that uh it shows uh us
and you know other teammates uh that are
sitting on the bench that we all can
sacrifice ourselves and you know that's
what we must uh pretty much been doing
um nobody's going to get the same shots
like I said before um you got to do the
little detailed things uh if you're not
getting them or if you're not playing
and if you are playing Just boxing out
knowing your rotations talking
running hard and playing hard um like I
said it's only so much the coaches could
do for you uh it's on us to come out
here and
compete